In this video we will study about
structure and function of DNA.
DNA stands for
Deoxyribonucleic Acid
and DNA is the molecule which is located
inside the nucleus of the cell
and its main job is  store and code the genetic information of the body.
For most of the life cycle of the cell
the DNA is located inside the nucleus of the cell
like a coiled noodle. But during the time when the cell
replicates, the DNA is arranged
in the form of structure, which are known as chromosomes.
And these chromosomes help keep the DNA stable
during the time of the cell replication.
Now, most of you are familiar with the double helix model
of the DNA. The double helix model
demonstrates
that DNA is basically a polymer.
To understand DNA now is a better way
you have to understand the definition of a polymer.
So the polymer is basically a molecule
which is consisting of many repeating units which are
known as monomers. If we take the example of a simple
polymer called a Starch, in this case
the repeating monomaniac units are known as glucose.
These glucose molecules are joined together by
glucosidic bonds and from the polymer
which is known as starch. In a similar way
DNA is also a polymer, in
this case the monomaniac units which form DNA
are known as nucleotides
This is the basic structure of a nucleotide.
You can see that it consists of three important groups:
phosphate,
the sugar,
and the nitrogenous base. Now if you want to study with the
details of the structure of the nucleotides
the link to that video will be in the description below
But in a nutshell you can conlude
that the sugar present inside the nucleotide
is called the Deoxyribose which is a five carbon sugar
which belongs to the ?
The phosphates group consists of a phosphorous ion
to which four oxygen atoms are attached
and then we have the important nitrogeous bases